[音楽]
これ身を守れ日本語やる方がいると思います
キャストの前に馬を置いてるんですけどこれ僕の家なんですね
募金はモバイルハウスに住んでます
好きなところで旅をしながら
自分の高友達の家の横に留めたりとかして
でも日本海側で寝たいなあと思ったそこに行ってみたりとかして旅をしながら生きてい
ます
家賃も光熱費もタダです
ヘッドもう2人で住んでるんですけど8ヶ月になりますね
皆さん思うと思います何で普通の家に住まないのかなと動く家に住むって一体どういう
ことなんだろう
移動する旅をする引っ越しするということだと思うんですけど一体これって何なのか
それは新しい出会いやこれまで行ったことがない場所に出会える
体験
もし行かなかったら一生1回もではなかったかもしれないそういう
唯一の奇跡的な分岐点を刺激的な体験だと思います
その環境変化する環境の積み重ねが人生をどんどん分岐させていく
それでもっとワクワクして楽しいライフスタイルになるんじゃないかと僕は思います
少なくとも僕はそうです
えっと僕は3.11のとき17歳高校生だったんですけど
イタリアに飛ばされました
イタリア人の友人が親に連絡してくれてモーション者の方だったらいつでも来ていいよ
大変だったら行くねってきたんですけど
荒野が明日チケットを張ったから癒さい言われてですねパワーされましたどぅどぇーす
か
パティいくんですよアフリカ飛ばされて
6年間済むんですよちょっと大変じゃないですか
大変なんですけどまぁなんとかなると頑張ると逆境に立ったらガンバです人間っていう
そうするといろんな経験できるもちろんいろんな人たちが友達ができて
助けてくれる人たちがいる a にちょっとこれ今日このこの子
逃げるっていう友達は君に来てくれてるんですねロンドンからわざわさ
で一緒に俺と一緒に働きたいからって
今1年間が2年間日本に十数の決めてくれました
そんなもうもし僕が入ってなかった絶対ありえないです
日本にその後いたら絶対起きてないです
でそれも積極的にいろんな人たちに関わり続けてきたからそれがブーストしたのが僕は
日本に帰ってきてから
去年帰ってきたんですけどまだ1年経ってないです
ユージが実はいなかったので6年海外にいるし持ちも方向線友達しかいないしみんな
話し合わないしそれ工建築勉強したんですけどその建築のコンペに入ってなんかこう
懇親会とかあるかとこういう友達できるんじゃないかなってもたまたま優勝しまして
まぁどうでもいいんですけどそれでもつながりができてあのーあのーもうし東京すすめ
のシェアハウス紹介
無料辞書紹介してもらったりそれで僕はもう1ヶ月日本帰ってきて1か月以内に6拠点
シェアハウスを転々とするってことができました
そこでですね
それから回り回って今ここに立っているんですけどなぜか
なぜてデックス東京会津今登壇しているのかっていう話をしようと思います
えっと今もくす i さっき紹介されたんですけどもモバイルハウスの会社を起業し
まして
というのもシェアハウスのうちの1つにあの今のパートナーとたまたまでやる機会が
あって
でもあっても1分くらいちょっもうちょい同じて強くだから一緒にジャンバランスの
歌手たちあげようっ
立ち上げてまぁそれもよしその一トリックって言う
佐土リクと出会わなかったら僕は今頃
ロンドンに戻っていますし大学院で建築を勉強しているんだそれも分岐点なんですね
それでリクあの出会った当初ですね借金に悪魔予定さっき200万円あってちょっと気
にせんでしょてじゃあやハロそれじゃあ
ちょうどいい屋上屋上にいい感じのくぼみがあるの知ってるつ
屋上にヘア作ってみます
作ったですね楽しかったです
鍋パしている時ですでしたらまあバレましてあるんですね
見たことありますが屋上生活者って7されて思ったんですけどバレて犯罪者扱いですね
それで
あのその時に彼が実は全部2をかぶってくれて
で僕の名前を出さなかったです管理人とかで悪いナッツっても本当申し訳ないとし
たってカフェでなくサービスです
デカフェで慰めてたらそのカフェのオーナーがその話聞いてて
内緒さんその話面白いですもう数場所ないんだったらシェアハウス紹介するからそこ
意気な奴って
でシェアハウスに行ったらあさっきファシリテータの活動さんがいまして
でその日も長女物で想い著
明日高校でイベントがあるんだけど競演教壇に立って高校生ちょっと希望みたいなこと
話して読みだで24時間以内に犯罪者だったんですよさっき前
24時間以内に高校で鏡面垂れてるんでしょこんな感じでわけわかんなきゃですか
まあこういうことが起きる
でまあまあその割愛するんですけどいろんな子出会いがあって
nhk でたりとかあのこれ参議院の登壇とかしちゃったんですね
ありえないんですよ普通に考えてではこういうことが起きる
要するにこの変化する環境に積み重ねっていうのが人生をどんどん分岐させるよねと
楽しくてワークは主体的に今を生きる自分そのいろんな分岐した選択肢の中で選ぶのは
自分だけどそれをとりあえず増やそう
で今現にほかもまだ1年も経ってないんですけど様々な人に助けられて生きています
木に通ってですね社会保障っていうのは国のシステム年金なんかじゃなくてリアルで
出会った仲間たちがです
でこの筋
70億人のうちの0.000音%
これは3万人なんですけ障害で出会う人数ですね
here 世の中に面白い人たちが山ほどよく面白い場所がてぃ者と家の往復だけでは
出会い運ラインで調べてウードゥーパティスリーア
れたら何が人気だってわかるだからこそそうじゃなくて
チャットなんかじゃなくてその人の匂いだとかしぐさなとかオーラとかそういうものに
興味がある
そういう価値観が大事だと思っています
でそれを突き詰めてじゃあそういうのをその物理的に人々と出会う
ライフスタイルこないなんなら考えてあのちょっとエクストリームなんですけど実用的
で究極の答えを生み出しました
それがあのその単体園しようとしてるの僕たちの会社散歩という
やつなんですけど
何なのか
コスモば入りしてるとハウスコアっていうコンセプトですね
超まあて説明します
あのキャンピングカーとた拠点シェアハウスの固有方みたいなそういうコンセプトなん
ですけど
その前に前提をお話したい生涯年収を1/3
この数字もあまあその生涯年収の平均だいたい242億8000万と言われたんです
けどまぁいったから9000万がないですね
これが昭和原家賃の音なんです
そうこんなに貼らなきゃがあったらその衣食住の住ですよ普通に生活する人間が生きて
いく
金だけ払ってたら前に働かなきゃいけないし
その自分がよかとかに使う時間っていうのはもうない
それで僕たちのマルセルっていうのは50万円ぐらいできる
1/100なんですよ1/100ですだ
僕たちはその月に4万円くらいあれば絶対知らないです
谷地0
で一畳半僕たちのモバイルする一畳半です
めっちゃ狭いですねでも断って半畳寝て一畳という
えっと言葉もあるんですけどまぁいっかこれ不思議になってなんでこんな豊かな日常版
でこれ豊かすぎるんじゃないかと思って比較してみたんですねワンルン
したら僕らの奴とこう床が引き出したりとか
極上に河野れたりとかで壁も全部使っている消費も収納も全部上から吊ってるんだ
だからもう普通のあの家へと比べ
でも同じくらいの面積を使ってるよとみんなもネガティブスペースだけでも値段は
100分の1メートル
まあこう試してみたんですけど21に乗りませ前
100人乗ってもみたいなね
100人乗れないですけど
でまぁ連結もするよこれ後でちょっと
おく必要になったでしょうかなんですけどまぁ連結すると
デコ wi-fi もあるし
あれ
えっ電気も通ってるからどこでも仕事ができる普通じゃあり得ないですよね
ででも僕達何がないかというとこれとこれがこれからちょっと特殊な例なんですけど
遠いでもキッチンも何もないと水廻りも内緒だから僕たちのこれって家じゃなくて部屋
なんですね
モバイルせるっていうの部屋っていうの猛虎に住んでるとパーソナルスペース以外は
は24時間必要ないんですよね数十分使えばいいんです
それがハウスこうやってコンセプト
そのインフラだとかコミュニティっていうのはここにあるバスルーム大臣切っちゃ
て身ぐるみ24時間が入らないんですねここに自分たちの部屋を持ち寄って家にする
ってこういうコンセプトなんですよそれがもうた拠点であればいいじゃないか
動いちゃっ
でこれも一つ一つにもテーマがあってひとつは護衛がハウスか映画好きが住みたい
でもしかしたら週末だけ啄木中アート好きならそのアートハウスコアアートの人が好き
な人たちが集まるところに週末行ってみよう皆面白世界ちょっといい気でもどんどん
普通も2年縛りとかいいと思う倹約はそんな者
毎日も動いちゃえばいい
ブーバーれ日本へへっ
あの
アキアっていうのがあと20年後には30%以上になると言われていますだったら一人
当たり
た拠点の
えっと別荘みたいなものを持てばいいじゃないそうすればもっと未来的で現実的な解決
策になるんじゃないかっていうふうにも思います
例えば高団地を回収しちゃったりとことでこういったい駐車場みたいでコーデバチカン
て来入るとかね
秋はもうに東京の一般アパートとかあるんだ
なあこれちょっとまあ後で漫画用意してるんだ4つ選んでほしいんですけどあんまり
説明しないですけど
いろんな人がこう常にねっと
去る者追わず来るもの拒まずにたあいつも戸籍がみたいに去っては入ってきて面白い
わくわくする良い
とかさっき合体するって言ったんですけどもうちょっとそうソロこう
彼女もできたし結婚したいし一緒にすごい月に国が着ブルー
パチンってなったら部屋が拡張される
部屋白鳥されシーマ次は子どもの中でも子供ができたら子供を作ればいいたんだ
では息子も家でできる可愛い子には旅をさせよというかたりすればいいです
いや動くん
そんな面白い世界が来たら最も自由で拡張的なライフされになるじゃないか
でこれで1回その僕たちのキザ
女
静か怒っておくしてございます
[音楽]
ウイ rear いいいいいい
サウンドはジェリーはぁ
中古車
th
ああああああ
えっなんで
naa
おい
ここでプレゼンは終わるんですけれども実はここまでは4強なんですよ
ここから人生を分岐させていきますじゃないですか
家が今僕たちも止まってるんですでさあ先に言っておきますけど
一畳半でしょ軽トラの後ろでも入ったらめちゃくちゃも広い先にときますけど想像より
すごい想像
ヒロインですこれは体験者できないでも言いたいんですけどそこのお前
ネットの多くでこの日開か本番ですだから今から品
代に入ると思いますありがとうございました
[拍手]